could it be that your success on YouTube
getting a thousand subscribers a hundred
thousand subscribers that actually
you're gonna win that battle before you
even post a video who is your channel
for what problem does your channel solve
if you're trying to reach everybody
you'll end up reaching nobody you want
to have a cohesive strategy if I was
going to start a channel from scratch
this year this is the system I would
follow to get my first 100 a thousand
even a hundred thousand subscribers
we don't rise to the level of our goals
we fall to the level of our systems and
in this episode of the think media
podcast we're actually going to be
breaking down something we haven't
really shared publicly like this before
and that is our 7R system that's a part
of our video ranking Academy and Nolan
and I are going to be going through all
seven R's so buckle your seatbelt and
definitely watch and tell or listen
until the end of the episode so that you
can catch all of this content if I was
going to start a channel from scratch
this year this is the system I would
follow to get my first 100 a thousand
even a hundred thousand subscribers and
so Nolan I'm fired up to uh really share
this in a context that we've never
shared before we've never gone this deep
on this training other than in our video
ranking Academy course and so this is uh
cool that we get to talk about this
openly with everybody on the podcast and
uh it's gonna be valuable the first R in
our seven step framework is reverse
engineer can you kind of break down what
that means and if you're a brand new
YouTube channel in 2023 how can you
utilize this first step to set yourself
up ultimately to know that you can
succeed in the end yeah so reverse
engineer is all about starting with the
end in mind and it's about answering the
questions of who is your channel for
what problem does your channel solve
it's also about getting Clarity of what
is the business plan for your channel if
you're trying to reach everybody you'll
end up reaching nobody if you're trying
to monetize in every possible Creator
Economy Way your focus is too divided
there's better monetization options for
entertainment and there's different ones
for Education it's it's getting clear on
those types of things it's getting clear
on who is your target audience and the
cool thing about the 7R framework is you
can apply it first to your channel so
we're talking about reverse engineer
what's your Channel about what's the
focus of the channel what's The Branding
of the channel but you also then apply
it to individual videos so you're maybe
posting a video and saying what's the
purpose of this video is it more of a
broad appeal bring in more subscribers
is it more of a it could be something as
like a channel update you don't think
it's going to perform well but you are
wanting to talk to a small number of
people that are actually see it that's
fine You just defined ahead of time what
the purpose is what I found is I was
really inspired by a 2 000 year old
quote from a military General named Sun
Tzu the book is very famous it's called
The Art of War and he said that every
battle is won before it's even fought so
could it be that your success on YouTube
getting a thousand subscribers a hundred
thousand subscribers that actually
you're gonna win that battle before you
even post a video and we say punch fear
in the face start before you're ready
there's something about like you should
be doing that anyways like just learning
practicing but when it really comes down
to to winning on YouTube and building
something significant you want to have a
cohesive strategy and that definitely
starts with defining your end targets
and getting really clear on some of
those questions I just put out there
yeah I actually have a failed YouTube
channel uh of course I don't love
talking about it because it's like it's
a failure but uh I haven't Failed
YouTube channel and I think I did I just
didn't do this step I didn't reverse
engineer and so I started a new channel
and I use this step reverse engineer and
one of the things that really helped me
uh decide what to make the channel about
and for someone listening if you maybe
are posting a ton of stuff you're just
trying to figure out what that Niche
what that topic of your channel should
be I found this super helpful and helped
my new channel actually succeed and not
be a failure uh which was I I asked
myself what am I passionate about that
that that which you you think that's an
easy question but like a lot of people
have so many passions and I'm definitely
one of those people and so what I did is
I went into it's not just what are you
passionate about you have to think what
do people want to watch because I might
be passionate about something that just
I like to play basketball if I were to
film myself playing basketball that
would not be very interesting because
I'm just not that good so I had to ask
okay well what do what do what would
people want to watch on YouTube and so I
actually went into my own history and I
started looking at what am I watching
and I noticed I was watching stuff on
productivity I was watching some like
basketball highlights I was watching and
I started to write these down because
there was different themes and this is
like this is kind of a major hack
because a lot of people they don't
they're like I'm watching all this stuff
on YouTube maybe you could make your own
channel on that and so that is like a
really cool tip to kind of bring clarity
to what am I watching because I'm
passionate about these topics
um and then what would be some advice
that you would give to someone who they
have a ton of different passions and
maybe their Channel reflects that I know
that early on you posted a lot of
different stuff
how do you narrow down and when do you
stop experimenting because sometimes
it's best to just just get started and
to try different stuff when do you
figure out to narrow in and kind of
become clear on what you're going to
post about yeah I do think that if you
don't have total Clarity which almost
nobody does when they start it's because
you need to post videos experiment
should you have a niche day one well you
may not need to because if you do Post
one topic a second topic a third topic
and you aren't getting views or growing
yet well then you're not violating your
audience you have no audience then maybe
you post 10 to 30 videos and they're all
different experiments and something
starts to break out I think what you
want to do I read a book they call those
bright spots if you're doing a lot of
different things in your life what are
the bright spots it's like if you had a
lot of different friends and you're like
I've been investing in a lot of
relationships but I feel like a lot of
people aren't reciprocating well who is
that's the bright spots and double down
on the ones don't worry about the people
who aren't calling you back go hang out
with the people that are you know invest
in the bright spots so which videos what
are the themes that are standing out and
then the whole other side of reverse
engineer though is also this
practicality of
coming with a business mindset and so
one of the most valuable aspects that
our video record Academy students learn
is we kind of come into the crater
economy wanting to just monetize our
passion which is good but there's a huge
skill Gap in kind of online business
online marketing leadership and so I
think if you only focus on passion that
you're missing the aspect of
practicality and profitability
so I think part of your focus should be
influenced by how much Market viability
is there here so some business terms one
is Tam the total addressable Market what
entrepreneurs novice entrepreneurs
actually follow novelty they follow
something they're excited about
pro-entrepreneurs follow viability which
would mean
uh is there a lot of people that need
their garbage picked up great I should
start a garbage business are you
passionate about it no but I'm I'm
passionate about providing for my family
or making a difference or this business
that I'm starting over here so usually
in the passion economy the Creator
economy it's like passion is King I
think if passion is the only King though
it's like passion is King but
profitability is Queen and she runs the
household like you need to have a
practicality and a profitability to it
so reverse engineer would have to do
with thinking about some of the market
research so you knew you love basketball
you also identified your proficiency
that if it was you teaching basketball
or being on camera or teaching people
how to 360 dunk that probably wouldn't
no really work but then understanding
how to use fair use and kind of a face
entertaining content around NBA which I
you know enjoy watching those kind of
clips and stuff yeah and it and then it
blew up and and an and because of what
she would learn you have that that that
savviness there the last thing I would
say is this kind of a cool thought
exercise you know when people think
they're limited financially one of the
things they could do is they could get a
loan now I'm not suggesting someone runs
out and gets a loan but you can get a
loan to start a business and starting a
YouTube channel is like starting a
business this is not like a radical
concept this is what businesses do
historically you go to a local bank and
you get a small business loan so let me
ask you
are you prepared to present the vision
for your YouTube channel to a banker
that's going to determine whether or not
they fund your small business loan I'm
not suggestion you go get one you
actually we actually do have a partner
that's how we can link to them in the
description where you can actually get
an LLC set up for free and you can um
they do have the ability to extend lines
of credit if you're serious that can be
jet fuel for a good plan the cool thing
about that is that ultimately uh if the
banker like goes they say so how are you
gonna make money like I'm not sure uh
what's the market value viability of of
this channel what's kind of like the
competitor assessment what's kind of
happening here oh I really haven't done
that they'd go well I'm not going to
give you the go get to work and and what
they would want to see is a business
plan and so that's one of obviously we
we got to go through all the R's but one
of the we spent a lot of time inside of
the video record Academy program getting
clear on this stuff because it's the
foundation like it doesn't matter the
the the paint on the walls or the art in
the walls that's the title and the
thumbnails that's all cool but if the
foundation isn't solid then the whole
structure is not going to last it's
going to fall so reverse engineering and
getting clear basically the business
plan your YouTube plan your money plan
kind of the Synergy just different
language for some sort of the same thing
you're reverse engineering the whole
picture and then success becomes
honestly inevitable every battle is won
before it's even fought like you're
sitting down you're like I know the
battle is one I've got the right pieces
I got my strategy dialed in now it's
just a matter of executing on the
strategy because you started with
Clarity by reverse engineering I'm
really glad you mentioned that it's
passion and profit because thinking back
now the reason my channel failed I was
only focused on profit and so it and so
I'm glad that you said that because I
was going into a niche that I wasn't
passionate about but I was like this
could make a ton of money and then I was
like burnt out trying to do it because I
was like I I don't enjoy this it's both
it has to be both I love that so the
second one is research and um what what
does that look like once you've kind of
you reverse engineer you kind of have
that business plan for your channel
you're clear on what uh you're gonna
post about you kind of have this is how
I'm going to monetize and be able to you
know go for full time and you've reverse
engineered the research phase is the
next step and what does that look like
yeah so now if we're clear on what who
our channel is for what problem we're
solving we can go through the 7rs every
time we create a video so at this stage
you may have an idea and now you're
going to research the idea and even
determine does this one video have good
potential this could include keyword
research this could include Google News
researching Trends this could include
studying competitors looking for
inspiration from their ideas it also
could include not even having any ideas
and using a tool like vid iq's daily
ideas tool that might feed you in that
case AI
or software in a way it's doing research
for you yeah you could research could
include studying how much search volume
there is about a topic or it also could
include
um going to a conference or looking at
the summary of a conference like uh CES
is the Consumer Electronics Show in Las
Vegas and one of the things that
actually helped build think media was we
were boots on the ground at CES five six
seven years in a row it's like a tech
show there's a lot of new cameras coming
out yeah that kind of stuff and so it
was a it was also it was like a hot spot
for creating multiple videos we would go
down year one because people are like oh
easy for you to say we would go down you
had people filming no no no relax
Rebecca like I would go down with a
manfrotto monopod a Canon 70D with the
screen flipped at me and a wide angle
lens like 11 to 22 at 11 and I would
hold that out on one arm so my arm
wouldn't get tired with a wireless
Sennheiser microphone and I would
interview people at booths take the
camera off shoot all the b-roll so
there's levels to it where you can do it
solo you can do it with one person
helping you Ron Starling came one year
who kind of intern with think media and
then fast forward eventually we were
like rolling in Squad deep with like you
know five six seven of us just step you
know one video at a time one brick at a
time but going there there a lot of
research was happening in the effect of
you're seeing what's happening in the
market you're seeing which Trends are
coming which they're Trend surfing
you're Trend surfing you're leading to a
lot of content ideas but the other thing
you might say well I can't forget Viva
being solo I can't afford a plane ticket
or fly there you can cover
a show in your industry just by looking
at the headlines and the news articles
and reacting to those Omar was just
talking about how there's a guy going
viral for real estate in Vegas and the
video that's going viral like 400 500
000 views it's just a loom video it's
him with a little screen recorder screen
record his face in the corner but it's
the value it's the context and the
commentary that he's giving on reacting
to data charts and those types of things
so when something like CES comes out you
could type in CES Consumer Electronics
Show Las Vegas and then you could go to
the news Tab and then the normal Google
tab and read and follow and study so
research there's if we go into such
layers of depth inside of the program
but ultimately it's not just like
keyword research it's kind of like topic
research being aware of what's happening
in your industry could be watching some
other YouTube videos and then
synthesizing that information
into coming up with a great video and
notice we haven't recorded a video yet
you know we haven't actually prepared it
and the other thing that research would
include in this 7rs is that we are also
going to synthesize this into a concept
that we will record which is a future
step right so so it this includes also
then getting your outline together by
your goal by the end of this R would be
okay what is my title kind of what's the
hook and I don't mean the opening I mean
like what's going to grab people topic
wise what's the how's it how are you
going to grab people with the topic and
the title so I would oftentimes go home
even when we were here physically for
CES because we were still a small team
and there was companies like The Verge
that had a double wide trailer that
rolled up with 50 journalists that were
in laptops and hitting the show floor so
as a small Creator especially early days
as a one man or three-person show I
would research at the evening before day
two of CES and I would be like oh wow
they discovered 13 things I didn't know
about and you didn't have to be here
physically there are other people that
can kind of be feeding you if you know
where to look and where to find things
and so um yeah that's that's research
and then or and then I would go back and
I would pretty much know my title I
would know the hook I would know like
the the first 8K camera I'm like oh I
didn't know that was here and so once I
saw that that existed I studied up
learned about it whatever and then I
turned that into a video and and I was
able to uh leverage great research
resources to help me go further Faster
come up with strong video ideas and then
ultimately when you follow all seven of
the R's it's a provable system so then
already this should be like every battle
is one before it's even thought like
that video was a strong idea it was
refined it was dialed so if I follow
through on it it was like basically
guaranteed to win maybe it doesn't go
viral but like it's gonna be a quote
unquote successful YouTube video one of
the really practical advice I want to
give on this step of research kind of
going macro level is there's just to
dumb it down there's basically two pools
that you can go after when you're
because people struggle coming up with
what ideas do I make make so you have
like browsing suggested which is when
you go on YouTube you open up the home
page YouTube's recommending content you
you want YouTube recommending your
content and then you also have search
based where people are going into the
search bar and they're looking up video
ideas so I would encourage people
listening to this in your Niche go to
your home page hit the refresh button
and this is assuming that you're posting
content that is
um you know showing up on your home page
and find some inspiration from like
videos that are doing well and find a
way to I I typically when I find a video
like Oh I like that idea I'll save it to
a playlist I'll make it different
um and that's one way where you can you
want to find videos and it's pretty easy
on the home page that are getting more
views than subscribers and that just
kind of shows that like there's a lot of
interest in this topic you should maybe
make a video on a on a similar topic and
then another one the search bar that I
love that you talk about and you go way
more in depth in video ranking Academy
is going into the YouTube search bar
typing in best camera spacebar and sing
for beginners for vlogging for outside
and like those are all video ideas and
so those are just some like really easy
ways to just start the research method
the next part to that once you kind of
decide what video to make though would
be record so what kind of tips do you
have for this record stage when people
got it locked in they pull out the
camera what's next yeah so actually I
think because we haven't talked as much
about
four through seven of the R's I think I
would just recommend some resources here
number one
subscribe to think media this is our
think media podcast Channel you and uh
Omar are the greatest of all time in
terms of a lot of details about
recording videos in fact sometimes
people wonder like what's the difference
between video record Academy and think
media like a lot of what we give away I
think video record Academy isn't a ton
of how to actually make the content it's
the whole strategy it's getting all
these pieces it's the it's getting the
shortest path to earning big money with
a small Channel all that stuff we give
away pretty much everything free you
have a two hour online course
essentially on Final Cut you've got
um a lot of the today's pop popular
cameras either you or Omar have done a
five to ten part series on how to use
them so I'd say number one
um definitely I'm sure most people here
are but you know subscribe to our main
Channel think media and
some advice would be to approach the
channel though with less random intent
and more intentionality so actually to
maybe go visit think media asking
specific questions like do you already
have the camera go study that camera on
think media have you picked out your
software
commit the time to go watch your final
cut if that's the software or iMovie you
got both like go study that block time
and go really master that skill set in
regards to record secondly
um we also do have uh we were talking
about before with Mel if you go to VRA
podcast.com you can get a special
discount on the video record Academy
course if you not if you don't just want
to master all seminars but inside of the
course we talk we do a couple breakdowns
with like 19 distinctions review like
reviewing a video of how you could
improve your video so there's a lot in
there the perfect video recipe
um but whether you subscribe to think
media if you want to join video ranking
Academy and definitely a topic for the
future because that we could talk about
100 different podcasts I'm making great
videos so I think it'll be cool to get
into some of the other ours I do think I
have one question because I think a lot
of people struggle with step one and two
when it comes or sorry they do really
good at one and two and they spend a lot
of time there I'm this way so I'm kind
of just speaking from personal
experience and I can reverse engineer
all day long come up with my business
plan I can do research for months and
figure out the next 100 videos I'm gonna
make but then I actually don't pick up
the camera and hit record and I think
it's because I'm scared I'm like I feel
like I'm gonna be awkward on camera and
I think a lot of people struggle with
that part of it we don't talk about that
as much on think media we have very
practical
um stuff so what would you say to that
person who they're in a hamster wheel on
step one and two and once it comes to
actually pulling out their phone or
their their camera to start recording
they just can't they can't do it what do
you tell that person I think that what
we're facing as creatives myself you
everybody listening to this we're facing
what Stephen pressfield calls the
resistance
and that's what it is because there's a
little bit of Safety and Security in the
reverse engineer phase there's there's
Safety and Security in the research
phase and there's some dopamine
happening in our brains because what
we're seeing is we are we're getting the
light bulb moments we're like you're
dreaming big that idea will work you're
seeing you're like man if I if I do this
when when I do this I'm going to add it
to the list and the other thing though
is there also is some comfort there
because I I you might be like me you get
into a whole vibe wherever you work you
got your home office you work in the
corner of your bedroom and you get up
you make some coffee you got a little
breakfast over there put your headphones
on you're listening to some music you're
researching you're having some fun
you're still in your boxers though like
whatever it's a more you got a little
hoodie on it's cozy it's warm your hair
is just like yeah your hair is not your
comfy and you you you are being
productive but you're you're giving
yourself it's only one aspect of
productivity so what Stephen pressfield
comes up and I know you'd recommend it
if you're listening to this and we'll
link them up the war of art is a great
book basically the shorter version is
called do the work a lot of people will
read the book do the work yearly if not
whenever they get into a rut of not the
resistance is the procrastination it's
the it is the fear but I I also kind of
want to call out a little bit of
people's laziness like I mean you're
listening to this podcast
it's the fact that you got to get up out
of your office chair and get into the
shower and get ready and it's easier to
sit at your desk and do research than it
is to get your light kit out of the
closet and clean up the office and set
it up like because it's the work that's
why Stephen pressfield wrote the book do
the work because you're like and then
and knowing that even setting it up is
kind of exciting but as soon as you get
on camera you fumble and you stumble and
there's a little bit of brain fog and
your Energy's a little bit low you have
to press through all of that resistance
so the third R is where the rubber meets
the road it's it's the time where
whether it is fear or apprehension or
self-doubt or imposter syndrome but it's
also I think a lot of us are hiding
behind like even those things we could
be hiding behind because it's also just
laziness if it feels oh man I just maybe
I'm gonna put it off till tomorrow no
don't put off till tomorrow what you can
do today you really have to just punch
procrastination and laziness in the face
and and get to work and and it's
something about get the prime the pump
you know they oftentimes say uh in a
good book about habits it might have
been Atomic habits it was like or tiny
habits it was like if you want us to
develop the habit of flossing your teeth
don't think that
go floss all your teeth floss one tooth
like because if you floss one tooth
you're gonna be like that's dumb why
don't I just finish so but that you're
tricking your brain by being like I'm
gonna floss one tooth so if you're like
set up the light kit sit down and just
record the opening of the video like I
just record the intro like so you you
Niche down but like what a waste you're
like I'd have to re-get-dressed tomorrow
and put my you know whatever on like I
might as well finish the video so like
getting it started getting that momentum
going getting away from your desk even
if you film at your and like actually
pressing record I think um you really
just got to do it and those that would
be the simplest one if you get one book
get do the work by Stevens pressfield
we'll link it up that that is a must in
every creative's library and I love
revisiting his his work his newest book
they're all pretty similar but they're
all good is put your ass where your
heart is put your heart where your ass
is it's what's one of the and it's
really good I just say it's not they're
not very long and it's also it's kind of
a similar thing it's about like your
heart is in it to create this but like
get moving put your body there get on
camera and he goes into a lot of it
actually is a different than his other
books
[Music]
if you want to learn more about our 7R
system for starting and growing a
successful YouTube channel then we have
a special offer just for think media
podcast listeners if you go to
vrapodcast.com you can get access to
exclusive pricing special bonuses and
actually go read some stories and learn
exactly what this program will do for
you if you're serious about YouTube
right now this program has transformed
people's lives from many different
backgrounds whether they're
entertainment or education channels
whether they're business owners or
service providers or whether they're
stay-at-home moms or pastors or
ministers that are trying to figure out
how to get their message out there or
create extra streams of income I want
you to definitely see just some of the
stories and you can check all of that
out at VRA
podcast.com that's just for you and
because you've been a part of the think
media podcast community and I hope this
episode has added massive value
subscribe if you're not subscribed and
we will see you in the next one